كمان مساء الخير
[تصفيق]
بيقول اعطني مسرحا اعطيك شعبا عظيما
واليوم حضراتكم عظماء بهذا المكان
ما بعرف اذا قوي
ان اسمحولي
يمكن اخذ هاي العباره نحن نصنع المكان كي
يصنع المكان فيما بعد
لكن اثنيناته الحقيقه اني اخذنها من قبل
خلدون اللي بقول ان خلاص الظواهر
الاجتماعيه والاقتصادي
تفسر بالعمران هنا
يعني للمكان
الحقيقه المكان والانسان لعمر واحده
التحول انا بدي احكي لكم اليوم عنا هي عن
المكان وعن الانسان بس شو يعني التحول
يعني موقف
خلال لحظات حاتم حاسمي
يؤثر فينا داخليه
شخصيتنا بيولد قرار داخلي
ولاده التحول
الحقيقه اليوم انا بدي احكي لكم عن تحول
مكان متحول الانسان
المكان هو مدينه حمص القديمه الانسان من
هذه المدينه
المدينه مرت كثير الحياه
اول مرحله كانت مدينه تبريديه
بعدين صارت مديني شوي شوي عم تفقد قل
اسم
مخطط تنظيمي
والاسف كان بدايه
كابرس يا عمر
اجا حدا كمان هالمره
مع بعض الحقيقه اني اساور للمدينه القديمه
اجت مرحله بعدها من 67 الاحد كمان السكان
المحليين والمخططين المحليين
كمان كملوا للاسف الكارثي
هذا المدينه على امل انه يصير في عنا
المدينه او بالاحرى هون
بلش الناس ما تهتم بالمدينه الحياة
بالفتره اللي بعدها
على امل انه يتعدل المخطط تنظيمي بالفتره
اللي بعدها
الحقيقه الناس كملت ما المخطط تنظيم
اعطاءهم
بعد فتره السنه
وبعدها كملت المدينه طبعا بلشت هون
بالذوبان بلش
النسيج البيتوني يطلع على سنسيج القديم
خلال هالمرحله هيئه الطفل كان هو عم يتطور
مع المديني انا ارجع مره ثانيه
الطفل هذا هو المر بالمراحل التحول خلال
تحول المدين
كان
عم يشوف شو عم يصير بالمدينه من سكان
المدينه
فاول موقف صار معه الحقيقه في مدرسته كان
عنده مدرسه كثير حلوين اسمها
هاي المدرسه فيها الوان بنص الايوان حجر
من فوق مديرا علم لما
تطلع بهذه الحجره من فوق الحجر سوداء
يسمون المفتاح
فالحقيقه
كلياتنا تعلمنا النشيد العربي السوري من
مديرنا وكان في بهاي المدرسه كان فيه مصدر
هذا المصب مكمل اسرار لهذا الطفل لانه امه
مره انه لما حدا بيضايقك تروح وبتصلي
لسبعه
[موسيقى]
فهو كان الحيه اول ما يرن الجرس على هاي
القراءه
ويحاول يحكي معها او يسمع اسرار الكنات
ورصص الحموات
يمكن ان يسمع يمكن كان يشوف ماني متاكد
والنسف شديد هاي المدرسه
طلع قرار بازالتها كانت اول مره هذا القفل
الحقيقه ما من هاي المدرسه غير سباط هو
موجود اليوم انا كان مخطط هو رقم واحد
بالمدن العربيه مع بعض
هويه المدرسيه الحقيقه معكم للاسف شديد
الموقف الثاني هو الحقيقه
هذا الملل اهله عنده المحل بشارع باقول
هذا الحديث هو
الحد السري اصلا اللي بيوصل احياء المديني
معرفه وكان بالنسبه له او الاحرف بالنسبه
له لان ان هذا الطفل كان بالنسبه هو الحبل
السري
والسر معنا الحقيقه انا خلال هذا المحل
تعرفت على بيت حمص وتعرفت على الديمق
وكان والد يعرف كل الريش وكان يحكي لي على
كل الريف وحكم مهنتنا
للاسف الشديد ما الخط التنظيم بهذا المحل
هذا الحقيقه المخطط الكوجينز اللي هو بهذا
اللي اسس لانه الاقارات اقتسح واشياء من
المدينه عقارب لا تتاسر بهذا الاكتساح
اللي انعمل بحمص
موقف الثالث
هو
اللي طلع على ساحت فيه حلوين ونحن الحقيقه
كنا نلعب بهاي الساحه
وكان يومك حديث بالبيت انه المحل رايح
والبيت رايح كمان
شو هالحظات
بس بتتذكر امي الله يرحمها كانت تقول لها
عباره يا ابني شوف اخواتك ربما اما نحاكم
بس انت لا عندك لا بيت ولا محل ما لك غير
العلم
وبس
حطيت قدام خيار واحد بس والحقيقه انا ضليت
عايش بالهنا اليوم ما عندي ابدا فرصه انه
انا اتطلع وراه ابدا
طيب
البيت اسال حالا
سالته مين هذا اللي هو بيقارع المخطط
تنظيمي وبقرر
حياه الناس فقالولي هذا مخطط شوف شو بدنا
نسال المخطط المهندس نعمان طيب
معناته بسيط مهندس معماري وبعدين
الحقيقه بعد ما طلعت نتائج البكالوريا
خلاص انا رايح باتجاهنا ان اكون معماري
دور على حدا اذا ببني على المسابقه
حسب كان اول مهندس مع الوالد يتعرف عليه
اخي اخذنا لعنه على مكتبه قاعد مع مجموعه
بس
بدك تفوت يا الف قلت له عم فكر فوت عماره
قال لي والله
وشو بدك تعمل ليك احنا قعدنا ونشوف لك اي
شغله تانيه فانا بحبها
فبكي المره التانيه بعد ما بقينا
او بعد ما بقيت انا ورفقاتي لما مامون
وفرجت الحقيقه هم بسيطه
انا عمرك 18 سنه وكانه حطب لك وجه هذا
المهندس استمرت
40 سنه
بعد ولا يهمك نحن بنروح على المهندس
معماري تاني ما كان على موبايلات رحت على
باب المحل
مهندس رائع
صوت رائع شكله رائع عطره رائع
اخي قال له ان هذا اخونا بدنا صوت عماره
فلم
يا سلام
زاد المعماريين معمارين
شو هذا يا سلام
ارجوكم
الحب من اول نظره الاول
عنده بنته او ابنه بده يفوت عماره انا
بحشد لهذا اللقاء معه ابنه او بنته
لما الدكتور يتعلموا اولادكم صيدله او
مهندس او طبيب او اي شيء على كيفكم
الحقيقه على شغل
انا لما بروح على كليه
طبعا ماركه ما بتكون
خلاصه
كانها
سنه الرابعه
تطور عماره والناس كانت حاسس ان هاي
المدينه درجه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
القديمه لما رفع على المدينه القديمه فانا
بعرف
ومفلان الباب
كان رايح مع الماني
استاذ بنظريات العماره بجامعه
بعد ما شافوا المدينه القديمه وانا كنت
ماشي معهم الحقيقه
هذا الرجل هذا الاستاذ وكان بكثير يعني
لغه الجسد تبعيته ما بعرف شو
بالالماني فانا
الله يخليكم قال بعدين قلت له لا لازم
نقول تفعلون
بمدنكم ما فعلت الحرب في بلادها
سؤال عباره عن صعبي المره واحده حسيت كانه
عم يشتغل عندك كله
هاي المدينه انا بغار عليك كثير
[موسيقى]
الموقف الثاني خلال تطور المدينه الموقف
الثالث اللي هو بالنسبه الي كان نقطه
فاصله خلصنا عماره
عين شمس خلصت
القاهره خلال الف عام خصوصا هيلفتها
تعلمت اشياء كتير
محافظ عضوية
اتحايل على انه نجمد المدينه لمده
فكان السؤال شنو كان نعمل بهالسنين
فالحياه تشكل درجه حماه الحمص القديمه
وانا ومجموعه من
الاثار والسياحه والبلديه
من اول وجديد شو كنا بدنا نطلع
37 عقار اسد 37 اثري 64
تراثهم من قصه 3500 عقار ليس بالامكان
القرن ما كان كانت نوع
يه بس
بهاي النجمه
خلص المدينه
انا اليوم كان لازم اسالكم الحقيقه
وارجوكم انتم رايحين كل واحد يحط اربع
كلمات المدينه القديمه
كان التعليم
الاسرائيليين الجزء الاول بيقول خلص ما
عاد عن مدينه وجسم الثاني بيقول
المدينه القديمه هاي هي عباره عن مجموعه
من المفردات نربطها بالمواد سياحي خلاص
واليوم طالع عليه لقب المرسال الذهبي شكرا
نعملها طيب
انا الحقيقه ما هنعديني انه هيك اعمل
بالمدينه
يكون عادل كان عندي شغف ارجع اخدم المدينه
هاي الان تعلمت فيها وعملت فيها
ونسبي فيها واصدقاء منا
لازم اعمل شيء طب شو لازم اعمل
الحقيقه انا لفت شفت انه هذول الناس
كلياتهم متفقين على انه المدينه القديمه
هي نسيج محترف
شافوا حمص الاذيني
هاي
طبعا هي ما كانت هيك نحن ما استلمناها من
اجدادنا هيك
اجدادنا المدينه القديمه اللي احنا
بنشوفها
بنسميها ونرجع له وفي كثير مواقع على
الاشياء
التي كانت
كانت متماسكه نسيت متضامن رائعه
الحقيقه اللي صار
ممكن نعمل بالمدينه
فانا رجعت لهي
ما كانش داوود لحضرته الجار حضرتها
شو يعني هذا يمسك
وبيسحب الخيطان من هون وبحط مع بعض وبرجع
بحكيك النسيج الاول من جديد
طبعا
بحيات في النسيج
ما كان معلم ما بيستفيد
مرتب فالروح بتقع
الرقعه هاي ما بيجيب نتيجه شكلها ما حلو
ابدا فالحين انا هذا رجل كنت تشوفه انا
صغير يقعد عن كرسي في الشمس وعند نظاره
يبكي ماشي كثير غالي هاي ماشي
ما عندنا غير تركيا ما في حل غير هيك طيب
انا حطيت فردي ونشفت بالمجان الحكمي بحسين
عن مدينه المستديمه مشروع واحد مجمع
الزاويه
حطيت فيهم كل افكار والخبرات انا تعلمتها
انا بس اليوم جاي عليكم
[موسيقى]
لهذا النسيج
شفنا الحقيقه مثل القديمه في عنا شاب اسمه
الهدى واللحمه
شو يعني لحمه يعني بنت النسيج في ختام
خلفيه وبتتدخل مع خيطان
الحقيقه
المكان هو
المضمون هو الانسان
شكل وجوهر
سدق ولحمه نحن اليوم
بحاجه الى
ياتي النسيج الاجتماعي لتصير مدينتنا
مجتمعا
الحقيقه انا في العام
انه اربعه ايام بالشام
كل ما اروح على على الشام اجداد حمص وكنت
تحس فيها مقياس السعاده الاعلى
هذه الايام عم بحساوى الشام ما معناته انا
سعيد لا بالعكس جدا جدا
رجعت مع السعاده تصنيف المدن
الاجتماعي هو اهم معيار للسعاده مع احترام
لمستوى الدخل والحلقابيه والبن التحتيه
والرقميه كل شكل
الحقيقه نحن اليوم مديني حزين
في بعض التفاصيل
يمكن بالمحنه نعملها بالمكان وبعد
التفاصيل نحن بنعملها بالانسان
لحتى نرفع هرمون السعاده
بحاجه لسعاده وحضراتكم
جزء من صناعه السعاده
انا كنت عامل برزنتيشن حول النقطه الخامسه
الحقيقه انه نحن نصنع نقطه التحول عنواننا
نحن
بحاجه الى رفع مكاني عمران ابن قوسين هو
رسم مجتمعا
يعني نحن بحاجه نرجع من اول جديد كلنا
مجتمناه العلم مع العيله مع الجار الحي مع
الحي المدينه مع المدينه بس اماني شديد
البلا
د تتحول نحن بحاجه عناصر اساسيه خطاب
نثبت سياق
الحقيقه
يا ريتني كنت عامله مشتغليه لاني انا ما
بقدر بعمل حضراتكم وكلياتنا نحن نعمل رسم
عمراني
ومجتمعه شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]